but we're going to begin with a terrible
aftermath of hurricane Ian and the
growing questions about how evacuations
were handled now every day as a cruise
shift through miles and miles of
Devastation there are more awful
discoveries you could say the number of
confirmed deaths has risen to 86 in this
country that's the vast majority in
Florida more than 630
000 people are still without power today
and that number will hopefully continue
to fall as the recovery work progresses
Chris Van Cleave is in hard hit Fort
Myers was more on that part of the story
Chris good morning to you it's it's a
bigger mess and people realize it seems
well good morning Gail in fact this is a
pretty common sight across this area
debris everywhere the power is out some
neighbors here told us they're not even
sure if it's worth trying to rebuild
this house actually caught fire during
the height of the storm firefighters
couldn't get out here because it was so
dangerous and we talked to many
residents on this block who thought they
could ride out the Storm at home only to
find themselves literally running for
their lives to escape Ian's storm surge
that's over your head yes
to five five plus feet of water yes a
sobering moment for Vicky Markey seeing
the water line hurricane Ian Left Behind
inside her Fort Myers home so if you'd
stayed you'd have been underwater yes or
worse she got out not long before this
picture was taken by a neighbor up the
street water almost up to the roof line
when you look around your home right now
what what do you think
I had a lot of wonderful memories with
people I love
and I keep reminding myself these are
all things everyone I love is safe and
I'm alive across this community and many
others in Southwest Florida people's
lives litter their front yards
waterlogged memories from swamped homes
left unlivable thank you for the
Mitchells it's nearly 50 years worth
piled up around what's left of Mary
Jane's beloved baby grand piano from
here on out is this going to exist I
feel like we're existing but we're
really not living our life is right
there before and after satellite images
show just how life-changing hurricane
Ian's devastating path has been
with the death and damaged hole still
being tallied Fuel and water remain in
short supply for many according to
police this woman was arrested for
allegedly threatening another driver she
thought was cutting in a gas line
hundreds of thousands are still without
power and state officials are now
defending the timing of evacuation
orders in the Fort Myers area that some
say did not come soon enough when we did
our briefing 70 touch for the storm on
Sunday Fort Myers and Naples were not
even in the cone and so it was a
situation where those Folks at the local
level as that storm started to shift
then they took that data and then they
acted appropriately for Vicki Markey
it's a lesson learned take evacuation
orders seriously Vicky do you feel lucky
to be alive
very much so very much so
with all my heart and soul
at least two homes on this block caught
fire and burned down neighbors are very
very worried about the residents in that
other home they were elderly they had
decided to ride out the Storm at home
both of their burnt out cars are still
in the garage and they have not heard
from either of those residents folks
here are fearing the worst some good
news Vicki as she was sifting through
the rubble I want to show you something
she found she came across this American
flag it is incredibly special to her
she'd been flying it in her backyard to
honor her father a decorated Vietnam
veteran who passed away just six weeks
ago she tells me that flag is now her
personal symbol of resilience
she is planning to come back to this
neighborhood
coming to Fort Myers later this week
President Biden he'll be here on
Wednesday that is after he surveys
damage from Hurricane Fiona in Puerto
Rico Tony
Chris Van Cleef Forest down in Florida
among so many things lost and a few
things found Chris thank you very much